Ecuador's final televised debate began
with a minute of silence for the
candidate who was assassinated last week
we want to express our condolences to
the family of Fernando Villa Vincenzo
for his absence
fellow journalist Christian Sunita has
been chosen to replace the eviscencio on
the ballot but not in time to meet the
legal requirements to take part in the
debate
election campaign centered on the fight
against corruption and organized crime
with his killing the remaining
candidates will now have to use this
last presidential debate to try to
convince voters that they too are
serious about ending violence in Ecuador
Jean topic a wealthy security
entrepreneur is a trained sniper and
former member of the French Foreign
Legion he vowed to crush criminals with
an iron fist foreign
I will impose a zero tolerance policy
for Crime we will regain control of our
borders and reintegrate our intelligence
Services
wore a flak jacket and they all promised
to Target organized crime
but leading candidate Luisa Gonzalez
soon became the main target the
left-wing candidate represents exiled
former president Rafael Correa who was
tried and found guilty of corruption in
absentia
1.5 billion dollars that were wasted
during your government enough
many accused the Korea Government and by
association Gonzalez of having
persecuted opponents
we will strengthen the security forces
but not prosecute our critics
Gonzalez reminded voters of the Korea
Government social programs and years of
relative stability
but many voters had been hoping to hear
from Vivi census replacement and were
disappointed with the debate especially
the nearly 40 percent Who Remain
undecided
to see a Newman Al Jazeera Quito Ecuador